hello everyone and welcome to another
really wonderful game from the olden
days you guys enjoyed yesterday's game
so much I decided to throw in another
one and we will have the Tata still in a
few days so now let's check out a few
Classics while we're at it uh it's a
game uh from the 1922 tournament in
templates show now between Richard and
Heinrich wolf Rick had already really
doesn't need any introduction I mean if
you're into chess he he is one of the
strongest players of the early 20th
century he could defeat anyone and he
has proven that many many times if you
study theory of course you know about
the directi opening it's hard to be in
modern chess without knowing the name
meretti even um capablanca who went
undefeated for eight years suffered his
first loss in the 1924 Tournament of New
York um other than 300 so he he was just
a monster I mean he could crush anyone
and here his opponent is Heinrich wolf
we don't know much about about Heinrich
and we haven't had the pleasure of
having him on the channel so far but
interestingly he is known as the world's
first second that's a weird thing to say
I know but uh you know chess is weird
like that sometimes uh seconds in chess
are players who assist someone who is
fighting for the title so uh Magnus will
have seconds when he uh faced against
nip or against corvana or against
karyakin they also had sex and they
helped them prepare and Heinrich wolf
was one of the seconds that Emmanuel
Lasker chose for his uh for his 1908
match against them against the zigbar
tarash and
I think alongside alapin and yeah I mean
that's a pretty pretty big thing being
the first like that but also he was he
was a very strong player but not at the
level of for example
in those days so this game makes it all
the more interesting as something really
really awesome happens so let's check it
out and then we're going to discuss uh
stuff a little bit more so I it with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to D4 sorry
that's any pawn pawn to D4 we have Pawn
to D5 interestingly he does not go for
the 80 opening uh we have C4 E6 and now
Knight to C3 so standard Queens can be
declined we have Knight to F6 Bishop to
G5 and the bishop to E7 much like you
would see in a in a modern game we have
E3 castles and now Knight to F3 uh and
uh we have Knight B to D7 Rook to C1 and
now C6 uh closing the center here uh
nowadays you would see some like Bishop
to D3 A3 is also playable uh Queen to C2
also very popular nowadays is what uh uh
already goes for we have A6 and now C5
and C5 uh a bit of an anti-positional
move especially uh in those days
nowadays you can play anything really
and since white abandoned the struggle
for the center uh White is now allowing
black to attack the central with moves
like E5 or B6 B6 seems a bit more
natural because you have control over
the B6 square but that's exactly why uh
this game is so interesting and why
Heinrich wolf is such a such a a great
player he plays E5 here which is a pawn
sacrifice but not really in order to
keep the pawn you would have to perform
Miracles here so D capital is an E5 and
now Knight to G4 and okay he's going
after the E5 Pawn he's gonna win back
Bishop cat person E7 Queen capture Sun
E7 and now uh the okay this position uh
was reached once uh again after this
game a year after uh uh George Allen
Thomas played it against Giza marozzi
here he played Bishop to D E3 but his
maruti was a stronger player he was able
to win this with the black pieces but
here we have Knight the A4 and it is now
as of move 12 that this position has
never been reached again okay you have
additional Support over the C5 Pawn you
are planning to put the Knight on B6 if
black recaptures on E5 uh and your
knight on B6 will be fairly strong so
here we have Rook the E8 not going for
the E5 Pawn right away uh wolf wants to
continue developing and now Bishop to D3
putting pressure on this H7 pawn and
here interestingly you should give up
the H7 pawn it was not played in the
game maybe it's a bit too much to ask
but uh yeah you're never in any real
danger for example if you go on ID
captures an E5 Bishop captures an H7
which would be a terrible move a game
losing move if you will let's say King
to f8 and now you have to move the
bishop back otherwise G6 will just trap
the bishop so let's say Bishop to D3
knock on Knight captures an F2 and uh
White's entire position falls apart
everything is hanging uh but it's very
similar to what actually
happens in the game so after Bishop the
D3 H6 was played so he stops this and
now you should consider uh many things
one of them being Pawn to E6 it's kind
of the only move that allows white to
continue uh fighting here uh not easy to
spot and not easy to decide on this move
the one thing it does is that if black
captures with the F Pawn you no longer
have to worry about the queen Rook
battery along the E file and if Queen
captures then Queen is now in the range
of the White Knight so now you will
castle and now after Knight D to E5 you
can play Knight to D4 attacking the
queen and all of a sudden White's
position comes alive uh completely for
example Queen E7 now Knight comes to B6
attacks The Rook or you don't even have
to play it right away you can go Bishop
H7 check King to h8 and now Knight to B6
you attack The Rook after The Rook moves
now you play Bishop to F5 and white has
so much control over all of the squares
inside Black's Camp it's uh I mean it's
beautiful really for example Bishop
captures Knight captures and white is
having a great position also the Knight
here prevents Queen from coming to H4
but okay in the game after this H6 moves
played we have knighted the D4 right
away uh sort of preparing E6 but of
course black will not allow this after
Knight to D4 we have Knight captures on
E5 and now Knight the B6 attacking the
rook and A8 and it's very similar to
what we were discussing uh but uh it uh
well it's not really so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what uh already missed here while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well uh 10 move brilliancy and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course Knight captures and
F2 similar to the position we discussed
uh because now uh there is no good move
for white you could capture with the
queen you could capture with the king or
you could ignore capturing uh all
together what happens if King captures
well look at this Knight to G4 with
check and now uh either Knight captures
on E3 will finish you for example if
King F18 captures an E3 check picks up
the queen on C2 or if you play something
like King to E1 now Queen captures on E3
and white is without a move of course if
you try to block with Queen to E2 Queen
captures and C1 will be Checkmate there
is no escaping that the queen cannot
move the king cannot reach the F2 Square
so after this Knight captures an F2 you
cannot capture with the King what
happens if Queen characters well then
the bishop is left unguarded just Knight
captures on D3 check with a monster fork
and here you resign so of course after
Knight captures on F2 Bishop to H7 check
was played it is the only move white has
to keep on fighting King the h8 and now
again how do you continue the bishop
can't just stay there if you play you
could play Queen captures and F2 that's
perfectly fine you give up the bishop
and H7 now you castle and after black
Saves The Rook uh okay the game
continues let's say queen to C2 check G6
and now let's see Rook cte1 F5 sorry F5
and black has a spectacular position a
beautiful Knight here the the pawns are
Marching forward uh not much to worry
about here yeah but also it would be the
best way for white to defend here
however white castled and now the real
problem starts look at this Knight F to
G4 again you are going after the E3 pawn
and also you're repairing Queen to H4 to
go after Queen to H2 so what can white
do here not all that much it would seem
white captures The Rook uh it's uh it's
a good move as any uh Knight captures an
E3 now well it seems like black is just
gonna win back some material we have
Queen to E2 and now Knight captures on
F1 so white is not in a rush to
recapture on F1 the Knight really has no
Escape so better uh uh save the bishop
on H7 from being captured by the king so
Bishop back to B1 now black plays Knight
captures on H2 very nicely done by Mr
Wolf and now if King captures look at
this queen to G5 going after Knights to
G4 check and that's uh
that's just game if you move the queen
to avoid losing the queen still Knight
the G4 check came to G1 Queen to E3 with
check and now after let's say King H1
i2f2 check and you resign here so after
Knight captures on H2 Knight the B6 was
played uh getting the Knight back into
the game maybe hoping to eliminate one
of the possible attackers but now Knight
eat the F3 with check and now if Knight
captures then you blunder the queen on
E2 so your only other option is the uh
capture with the g-pawn moving the king
also isn't all that impressive for
example if King the H1 now you can play
Knight to G4 and now again how do you
defend uh does it doesn't really matter
what you do you could even trade Queens
with Queen captures and E7 but look at
this Knight to F2 Checkmate everything
is just falling apart here for white so
after Knight ETA F3 with check black
said all right I can't capture with the
queen I can't really move the king uh
let's play G characters and F3 but now
comes Queen to G5 with check it seems
like you are losing your queen but what
about Queen to G2 can you just block the
black queen like this not really because
the Rook on C1 is also hanging so Queen
to G2 would be met with the simple Queen
captures on C1 checked even you can
capture the Knight on H2 but now Queen
to F4 with check and the queen Rook
combo is just too strong also the Knight
on D4 is hanging but if Queen to G3 you
can simply go for Queen to D2 with
checking to H1 and queen captures on D4
seems like okay maybe white can defend
let's say Knight captures on C8 but uh
sorry not a rook just Queen to D1 with
check and now you win the White Queen
Rook D2 with checking H3 Queen to H1
with checking G4 and now Rook to G2 will
win the White Queen so after Queen to G5
check King captures and H2 was played
you have to give up the queen and now
wolf grabs the queen Rook captures on E2
Knight captures on E2 but now also Queen
to E5 with check into interestingly the
the Knight one captured I need to
defended The Rook so you can't capture
The Rook but not just Queen to E5 with
check okay now you connect with the
Knight but now the Knight moves Knight
the G3 blocks the black queen and if the
position remains uh White definitely has
compensation for the Queen the problem
is there's Queen captures on B2 check
and now you have to part with either
Rook or the bishop of course you're
gonna give up the bishop Queen captures
on B1 and now Rook to E2 and okay it's
Queen and Knight for a rook maybe you
can still play this bishop to E6
stopping any back rank checks and now
Pawn to F4 hoping to get F5 in for the
moment it's impossible because the queen
and the bishop are preventing that but
just G6 uh wolf says you are not having
any Contra play this game I am very
sorry to inform you of that so reti of
course will not resign he goes Knight to
day eight he will still try something uh
Ponte H5 just going for H4 at night the
C7 H4 and now after Knight the H1 just
between the D3 going after the Rook here
Rook to F2 and now Bishop to F5 and it
was in this position on move 32 that
rihadrete resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is uh you can't even make one move it's
very hard to imagine a movie you can
make like if you move the Rook away from
the file Queen to uh well uh the the
okay The Rook doesn't really have all
that many squares where you can move it
to but let's say you make a a single
move uh just Queen to H3 check and
that's all there is you couldn't stop
that even if you wanted to like King G1
Bishop E4 now threatens the Knight and
if Rook to H2 just Queen to G4 check
King F2 and now the Queen Bishop combo
will be more than white can handle Now
The Rook is hanging you have to defend
the Rook now Queen to E3 checking to F1
let's say Bishop to D3 check King to G2
and now of course Queen to E4 with check
King H3 and after Bishop F1 check uh you
have no more squares you have to block
with the Rook bush of characters King
somewhere and now you will get a
checkmated so a lot of moves about
basically it's
um uh I mean a very simple moves that of
course everyone will find so uh very
nicely done by by Heinrich wolf taking
down one of the strongest strongest
players of the era Richard like this and
it's not like ready had a bad tournament
or anything he even won the tournament
very nicely uh here you can see uh sorry
about that here are the standings of the
tournament of the 1922 tournament in
tablets Channel already won for shared
first place with Rudolph's Spillman so
if anything uh he managed to ruin it is
um uh clear first place by him by
winning this game but okay he already
has two losses in this tournament he
also lost the last place Paul Johner
um so those were his two losses in the
tournament but look at the monsters in
this
tournaments groomfield Akiba Rubenstein
Boris
Paul Johner all names uh I mean you
could not play Modern chess without
mentioning those names and the opening
ideas that you are using as basically
those guys were there when they were
founded so yeah I mean absolutely
incredible but yeah also I forgot to
mention in that 1924 tournament in New
York where uh already defeated
capablanca breaking his eight-year
undefeated streak uh also a cross
capablanca dearly I think um okay uh
Emmanuel Lasker one determined uh a
point and a half ahead of capablanca so
he didn't ruin capablanca's chances of
of beating Alaska to first place uh but
it definitely meant much Alaska wanted
ahead of capablanca and yeah
also in the same tournament he defeated
capablanca and alejin so I mean absolute
monster of a player uh which makes uh
Henry Wolf's a victory in this in this
game against threatti I definitely want
to show your friends in the bar and the
library uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it and that you've
learned a little bit about attacking
um if you play Such positions I would
like to thank 1984 dww Simon Johnson
ravishing reptiles YouTube and Francisco
masoko for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day